we love the new hybrid crew master from
fossil
it's loaded with cool tech features just
download the fossil cue app on your
phone and you're good to go for a sporty
look go with a nautical blue rubber
diving strap sync it with the app on
your phone to keep track of how many
steps you've taken miles you've run and
calories you've burned the strap matches
perfectly with one of our top style tips
this fall the track jacket a throwback
favorite that goes beyond the workout
what about a dinner date drinks to the
crew go with a stainless steel strap
striking confident and master a great
feature with this watch you can capture
the moment with the press of a button
take a picture with your phone how to
wear it
try a field jacket it's rugged and
elegant finally the office just because
ties are no longer required
doesn't mean that you shouldn't use the
Blazer just make sure it's fitted on the
sides and in the shoulder and for the
strap a personal favorite a NATO strap
it's a clever way to speak some color
into your office wardrobe the crew
master will notify you when you get a
text message or have a big meeting and
my favorite feature if you lose your
phone you can press a button and make
your phone ring one stunning hybrid
watch endless ways to wear it
you